[Music]
it began as a holiday
[Music]
arthur howitzer jr college freshman
eager to escape a bright future on the
great plains convinced his father
proprietor of the liberty kansas evening
sun to fund his transatlantic passage as
an educational opportunity to learn the
family business through the production
of a series of travelogue columns to be
published for local readers in the
sunday picnic magazine
[Music]
[Applause]
over the next 10 years he assembled a
team of the best expatriate journalists
of his time and transformed picnic into
the french dispatch
a factual weekly report on the subjects
of world politics the arts high and low
fashion fancy cuisine fine drink and
diverse stories of human interest set in
faraway cartiers
he brought the world to kansas
his writers line the spines of every
good american library
berenson
sazerac
kremens
robert wright
one reporter known as the best living
writer and quality of sentences per
minute
one who never completed a single article
but haunted the halls cheerily for three
decades
one privately blind writer who wrote
keenly through the eyes of others
[Music]
the uncontested cracker jack of
grammatical expertise
[Music]
cover illustrations by hermes jones
famously gracious with his writers
arthur jr was less courteous with the
rest of the magazine staff oh no what's
that
i need a turkey stuffed and roasted on a
table with all the trimmings and
pilgrims his fiscal management system
was convoluted but functional give her
150 francs a week for the next 15 years
against five american cents per word
minus expenses his most repeated
literary advice perhaps apocryphal was
simply this just try to make it sound
like you wrote it that way on purpose
his return to liberty comes precisely 50
years after his departure on the
occasion of his funeral by which time
the magazine circulation exceeds half a
million subscribers in 50 countries
a willow hamper containing umpteen pins
plaques and official citations of the
highest order is buried at his side
along with an andretti ribbon mate and a
ream of triple bond egyptian cotton
typing stock
[Music]
he received an editor's burial
in his will he stipulated that
immediately upon his death quote
the presses will be dismantled and
liquefied the editorial offices will be
vacated and sold the staff will be paid
ample bonuses and released from their
contracts and the publication of the
magazine will permanently cease
thus
the publisher's obituary will also serve
as that of this publication
all home delivery readers will of course
be refunded pro rata for the unfulfilled
portion of their subscriptions
his epitaph will be taken verbatim from
the stenciled shingle fixed above the
door of his inner office berenson's
article the concrete masterpiece three
dangling participles two split
infinitives and nine spelling errors in
the first sentence are wrong some of
those are intentional
the kremen's story revisions to a
manifesto we asked for 2 500 words and
she came in at 14 000 plus footnotes
endnotes a glossary and two epilogues
it's one of her best
that's the most
impossible to fact check he changes all
the names and only writes about hobos
pimps and junkies these are his people
how about roebuck right his door's
locked but i could hear the keys
clacking don't rush him
the question is who gets killed there's
one piece too many even if we print
another double issue which we can't
afford under any circumstances
a message from the foreman one hour to
press
you're fired
really
don't cry in my office
shrink the masthead cut some adds and
tell the foreman to buy more paper i'm
not killing anybody
good writers
he coddled them he coaxed them he
ferociously protected them
what do you think
for myself
i would start with mr sazerac
these were his people
see what happens next order the entire
movie the french dispatch now available
you